apple is going all out next month at
their big September event with something
we've never seen before the iPhone 15
Ultra which is a huge twist and the
Rumor Mill as I'll explain in this video
but if the ultra naming turns out to be
true it's gonna mean a couple of very
important things both good and
unfortunately bad so getting right into
it when last year's iPhone 14 lineup
came out Mark German instantly leaked
that the iPhone 15 lineup would include
a brand new rebranded Ultra model
replacing the pro Max however a short
while after that he updated us on the
leaks and said that Apple was apparently
delaying the ultra until the 16 lineup
but now we just got a new leak from
Apple insiders Andrew O'Hara claiming
that Apple will indeed use the iPhone 15
Ultra title for the larger Pro phone
according to multiple sources which is a
huge leak so based on that I'm gonna go
through a eight major changes in terms
of how the current leaks can change if
we do in fact get an Ultra phone because
with an ultra a whole lot of things can
finally make more sense starting with
change number one we have the Periscope
telephoto zoom camera which we've known
for a while was only coming to the
larger pro model and not the smaller one
but now with the rumors of the ultra
brand change it finally makes more sense
from a marketing perspective to be
honest the pro Max branding just doesn't
make sense because on the Mac side we
have both the M2 Pro and the M3 Max
chips so why combine both of those brand
names together for the iPhone's branding
it just gets really confusing on top of
that with the iPhone 12 lineup the pro
Max actually had upgraded features
compared to the regular Pro including a
2.5 x zoom camera compared to 2X and
sensor shift Optical image stabilization
which worked incredibly well but most
consumers had no idea that there was any
difference at all so if Apple finally
rebrands the pro Max model into the new
Ultra it'll be clear to Consumers that
it's Gotta Have Some bonus features and
the biggest one is going to be the
Periscope zoom lens which I believe will
actually be variable from around 3x to
6X Zoom with actual lenses that move
inside of that new camera and then this
Ultra branding move by Apple will be
very helpful to them going into the
future because they can introduce the
best camera features on the ultra first
and then bring them down to the pro a
year later like for example we currently
have a leak of a new 48 megapixel Ultra
wide camera coming to the iPhone 16
lineup next year so maybe it'll come to
the ultra first and now let's get into
number two 2 which is the titanium metal
chassis even before all the titanium
metal leaks started coming out earlier
this year as soon as Mark German
mentioned the ultra branding everyone
started speculating about a new titanium
metal model with awesome looking unique
renders like this one showing off a cool
new design that was inspired by the new
Apple watch Ultra and since Apple gave a
titanium finish to that new Ultra model
maybe Apple would do the same thing for
the iPhone 15 Ultra with an exclusive
titanium finish that you can't get on
any other model with the regular Pro
still sticking with stainless steel now
I know the recent rumors have pointed to
both the pro and pro Max getting
titanium regardless of the size but I
personally think it would have made
sense for Apple to only give titanium to
the ultra to make it more exclusive and
unique matching the ultra branding a lot
better and of course it would push more
people to buy the most expensive model
which would raise Apple's profits and
average sale price which they've been
trying to do for a long time now getting
into change number three this is the big
one that I'm personally very hopeful
about and that is Thunderbolt 4. we all
know by now that Apple's entire iPhone
15 lineup is switching to USBC but what
we aren't sure about is whether it'll be
a regular USB 3.2 port or if they'll go
with Thunderbolt and now with rumors of
the ultra branding coming to the iPhone
this finally wraps it all up and makes
perfect sense from a marketing
perspective Apple can give the ultra
Model A Thunderbolt 4 Port being 80
times faster than the current lightning
port in terms of transfer speeds sitting
at 40 gigabits per second compared to
480 megabits per second however the
regular iPhone 15 pro model can be
somewhere in the the middle at around 5
to 10 gigabits per second so only the
ultra will get the fastest speed which
makes a lot of sense but on top of that
we had further rumors from reliable
sources that Apple was planning specific
features in iOS 17 that would be hidden
until the launch of the iPhone 15 lineup
including a new Thunderbolt feature that
would give a live 4k camera feed to an
external monitor for live viewing so
hopefully that's how we would get a
thunderbolt port on the 15 lineup being
exclusive to the ultra model now number
four is actually a simple one but it
makes perfect sense Apple could give the
ultra model the best speaker system
especially since it would have the most
internal space at least compared to the
pro model and that's another way they
could differentiate the two models
number five is a big one that people
have been asking for for years and why
while there wasn't a technical
limitation to this apple might just give
it to us to sweeten the deal on the
ultra and that's the ability to
multitask with two different apps open
at the same time a couple of years ago
the plus-sized iPhone models could
actually be used in landscape mode with
certain apps but Apple completely took
that away so they could be waiting to
reintroduce that feature with the ultra
model and that would be another reason
to get one and moving on to number six
this one could be totally related to the
multitasking feature and that's an
upgrade in terms of ram we've recently
seen some mixed rumors from sources with
some claiming that the new a17 bionic
chip would come with eight gigs of RAM
but then unknowns 21 came out and said
it would only have six which was very
confusing well what if Apple decides to
give eight gigabytes exclusively to the
ultra model to help enable that multi
tasking feature and give it a
performance boost while only giving 8
gigs of RAM to the regular pro model
that could make perfect sense and now
getting into major change number seven
this is where it gets a little bit
disappointing last month we started
getting rumors that Apple would be
raising the price of the 15 Pro Max
model specifically from Tech analyst
Jeff poo and others who claimed it could
go up by two hundred dollars so my
thought was that maybe apple is only
planning to raise the price of the
biggest iPhone model now that they're
considering the ultra branding and
they're gonna hide the price increase
behind that new name with the extra
bonus features and to be completely
honest it could actually work quite well
because when the first iPhone 11 Pro
came out people paid the extra cash just
because they wanted the pro name for
that branding alone so maybe the same
things gonna happen with the ultra
especially since it worked quite well
for a Samsung and their Ultra models but
thankfully change number eight is one
that's gonna help soften the price
increase blow and that's the rumors of
Apple giving the Pro Models higher base
storage up to 256 gigabytes going as
high as 2 terabytes so what if Apple
decides to do this for the ultra model
only while keeping the pro at the same
128 gigs of storage that by itself could
easily explain the price increase and
add a lot of value when paying a higher
price because right now you have to pay
a hundred dollars to upgrade from 128 to
256 so it makes perfect sense for Apple
to do that so with all that said
hopefully you enjoyed this video and
learned something new and if you did go
ahead and subscribe above and check out
one of those two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]